now as a reminder the victim in this
case Jordan Neely was not the harmless
Michael Jackson impersonator like the
left wants you to believe this was a
person very sadly very tragically who
was seriously mentally ill he had 42
prior arrests including a kidnapping
charge after he abducted a
seven-year-old girl he also racked up
multiple violent assaults against
elderly New Yorkers and just prior to
his death while Witnesses told police
that Neely was making violent threats on
the subway and demands saying he didn't
care if he went to jail he didn't care
if he got killed here with reaction our
former New York City mayoral candidate
Curtis Sliwa Fox News contributor Leo
2.0 tarot good to have you both
it wasn't just Marine that got involved
this guy was threatening the people on
this train he didn't care about it going
to jail didn't care if he died 42
arrests sadly long history untreated
mental health issues but even violent
arrests this guy clearly was a danger
that motivated people to get involved to
protect the innocent people what does
that mean we're not innocent people
won't be protected going forward Sean he
was rated one of the 50 most dangerous
persons living in the subway system and
we see the Marine Corps they've been
there for us from the Halls of Montezuma
to the shores of Tripoli to the Subways
of New York City this Sergeant in the
United States Marine Corps came to the
aid of all the citizens there he could
have walked away like most citizens done
or observe what we call nyob mind your
business which has paralyzed our city
but he gets involved two other Good
Samaritans jump in he didn't even know
they hold them down they restrain him
he's telling the passengers call 9-1-1
they did took 15 minutes for the cops to
come because we don't have enough cops
all weekend long all the officials are
saying we're not doing enough for the
emotionally disturbed for the
schizophrenic we need to do more now all
of a sudden Alvin Brian gets a call from
two people
I'll Slim Shady Sharpton who says I want
him indicted for murder and I want the
two Good Samaritans indicted for murder
what are you out of your mind and then
AOC all out crazy Alexandria
ocasio-cortez scores a trifecta day one
she says he murdered him day two he
lynched him day three he executed him so
you have this gang of influential New
Yorkers ringing the phone of Alvin Bragg
who should not be taking their call she
shouldn't be influenced by anybody and
he has decided not to put it in front of
a grand jury because grand jury are
Subway Riders they would let this guy go
so he's handling him arrested tomorrow
and Prosecuting him there's a rumor you
may be running against AOC for congress
any truth to that should I should I take
on it
[Applause]
for the mentally ill I really do sorry
this but this guy has a history of
violence obviously it was enough for
three people to get involved the police
Curtis is right they didn't show up on
time the Marine was begging call 9-1-1
call 9-1-1 considering it's a Subway a
15-minute response uh time is horrific
so had they gotten there earlier had
they not been involved in defund
dismantle have they not uh alienated
police maybe this guy would be alive
because they would have gotten there
sooner and taken care of it
you're absolutely right but I want to be
very clear I don't want to mix any words
this is a racially charged prosecution
it's because the defendant is black and
the Marine is white that's I want to be
clear about that and the individuals
assisted this Marine were people of
color so I think this case is going to
go nowhere but the motivation is based
on race and they all that the left
always want this scenario shot a black
victim white uh assailant but this
Marine was trying to save those
individuals on that Subway and I
guarantee every one of those individuals
are going to testify on his behalf and
that's the issue here but this is all
politically motivated based on race this
is the ultimate insulting use of the
race card yeah well Curtis is right who
is ever going to want to stand up and
help defend the innocent on a subway
train knowing they may be prosecuted in
the end all right uh Leo thank you are
you definitely running against AOC hey
you keep by the way this Marine
is it all right
the Marine is a hero
tragedy in mind uh the cops should have
been there hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else